vodka company Smirnoff and this is real
we didn't make this up just release this
ad this is a real ad made in America but
would be happy to talk about our ties to
Russia under oath that's that's not a
joke that's a real ad yeah that Smirnoff
put out and I looked at that I saw that
and I said okay that's actually pretty
clever that's pretty funny
you know they trolled Trump with a print
ad okay it kind of cool but this is
what's happening now other brands are
trying to troll Trump with their ads and
I think I don't think it works as well
I just don't for example there's this
one Wheat Thins almost as thin as the
ice President Trump is skating on three
yeah that's a read that's a big read
yeah that's not so great they get worse
forever21
cover-ups sound familiar Trump
administration yeah look at this one CBS
we thought you'd like this ad president
Trump you know because it's a Red Square
go right-wing Queen let's not have to do
it there's nothing being a drug that's
just bad look at this one Allstate
collision insurance and now collusion
insurance here's one I hated this one
the lice comb our comb me also exposes
lies lights ads a register that as a
wrongful awful and it gets it gets worse
look at this one
depends adult diapers even depends
maximum couldn't handle all the leaks
coming out of this and finally there's
this one UPS what can Brown do for you
you'll never know we have Trump's travel
ban holds that's when that I realized
good
you